[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
for space science like nuclear science
and all technology
has no conscience of its own whether it
will become a force for good or ill
depends on man and only if the united
states
occupies a position of preeminence
can we help decide whether this new
ocean
will be a sea of peace or a new
terrifying dinner of war
china carried out its first
anti-satellite weapons test on an old
weather satellite about 500 miles up
according to u.s government officials
after three misses
china succeeded in shooting down one of
its own aging weather satellites
the test may be part of china's efforts
to establish a military presence in
space
does this mean the spy satellites the
united states depends on
could be shot down they left behind a
trail of garbage circling in orbit now
after they blow up the satellite
it could leave us vulnerable it could
[ __ ] us
is that what they're up to
there are nations out there who are
hostile to us
and they are in space the threat to our
space security
is real
security in space is a vital national
interest the loss of access to space
would threaten
the very stability of our nation
if aimed at commercial satellites and
such an attack could bring u.s
business and industry to a halt
today china warned that a shooting war
in space would affect everyone on earth
space can get more crowded and we're
going to need to have control and
defensive measures a treaty banning
space weapons has failed
a space war is in the cards space
is the backbone of our national security
there is no substitute
and there is no alternative to military
dominance
in space this conviction should drive
our course
for the next 50 years uh
[Music]
in the mid-20th century humanity spun
its first satellite
into orbit staking this new frontier
provided a new arena for war
still space is unscarred by battle
a sanctuary but humanity's compulsion to
dominate
may ravage the expanse embracing our
world
and the world itself whom can we trust
to regulate our heavens
[Music]
people in the roman empire lived better
under caesar augustus than they had in
any empire on earth
during any previous time
roads improved pirates no longer
threatened ships on the high seas
life was so good during this time
that the period acquired a name
it was and is still referred to as
the pax romana which means the roman
peace
another period of peace has acquired a
name
it is called the pox americana
or the american peace
[Music]
it refers to the period in which
american influence
throughout the world has caused a
relative peace to come about
nowadays it seems the pax americana is
threatened
most of us only feel peace when we're
not at war
but peace means the presence of a risen
and alive
lord in your life
you may walk out every morning into a
war zone
the lord won't take you out of the
valley of the shadow of death but he
will
lead you right through it
and so it says in isaiah 54 though the
mountains be shaken and the hills
removed yet my
unfailing love for you will not be
shaken nor my covenant of peace
be removed
my name is first class colton tuttle i'm
a cadet at the air force academy
i graduate in 44 days and i'm just
hoping to do my part to make sure that
everyone here can enjoy their freedoms
[Music]
pax americana is a political view
which simply says that because america
is
currently the sole superpower that it
has not only the ability but the
responsibility
into the far future to maintain world
peace
eyes
[Music]
i think our country has always played a
key role in maintaining world peace
and now that responsibility also extends
into space
and so when countries like the chinese
start attacking space assets
it could lead to a serious crisis
hopefully we can talk to them before
they start
making a big mess
the united states and particularly its
intelligence services
worry about an attack on the united
states
that is not nuclear weapons it is not
chemicals
that is not biological but is
technological
global communications are embedded in
our daily lives
miles above our heads beyond our
awareness
satellites manage our hyper-connected
society
if you look at space lots of times you
think about the hubble telescope or
you know mars probes but most people
don't realize that they use space
every day
[Music]
when you open your cell phone to make a
call
[Music]
when you take money out of the bank with
your atm card
satellite bring you your tv shows and
live news from around the world
you use them each time you rely on a
positioning system for air for sea for
land traffic control and even in your
own car
there will be no weather forecasting
disaster monitoring
without satellites our entire life
depends on satellites they're essential
but we're not conscious of that until we
lose it
today at least one thousand active
satellites circle the earth
[Music]
45 nations own these satellites
and most of the world uses their signals
but the united states dominates as the
owner and user of space systems
both civilian and military
bombs on target real-time battle
management
that's what we're about and that's what
we are able to
deliver through space air land and sea
and the the capability of all of those
to come together
we started that in desert storm we've
done that
in each conflict since and we get better
and better and better
since the first gulf war the use of
space has become vital to
all u.s military operations
in the second gulf war during the shock
and awe air attack on baghdad
the united states used satellites to
guide 71
of all the missiles it fired
space is the backbone of american
military power
or is it its achilles heel
a surprise attack in space this is uh
the ultimate nightmare by
knocking out 50 u.s military satellites
the
chinese could literally [ __ ] the u.s
military
they could prevent the military from
being able to communicate with its
forces
they could blind the us intelligence
community which uses electro-optic
satellites
to determine military force movements
around the world
and they could also [ __ ] the guidance
systems that are used on precision
guided munitions that are satellite
guided
in many sense it could be a kind of an
electronic pearl harbor
without space the u.s would be unable
to conduct any type of military
operation
in an effective way
[Music]
there's a tremendous premium on the
united states being able to prevent
other people from attacking our assets
in space
and to ensure that we can continue to
exercise
full use of them and if necessary also
to be able to deny others
use of similar assets for their own
purposes
[Music]
the world has changed as more and more
countries develop a presence in outer
space
the possibility of a space battle is no
longer science fiction
our new world requires new solutions
meet u.s
air force base command this elite force
is america's eye in the sky
keeping watch over our interests high
above the ground
[Music]
denial implies the use of force
weapons from space to the ground as
china recognizes
that the military dominance the united
states is utterly reliant upon space
the united states is going to become the
world's policeman
does that title resonate with you do you
have any reactions to that do you think
is accurate if it were accurate how
would it play out
if you look at what was one of the first
roles of the united states navy when it
was established was
combating piracy and uh if you look at
you know potential commerce in space law
enforcement and uh
things like that are going to be an
important mission as more and more
countries
start using space for security purposes
and military purposes
uh sooner or later they're going to
collide and sooner or later space will
become another arena for warfare
for good or bad and the same kind of
ethics that we apply to military force
in the other environments will apply to
space
you can obviously stretch any analogy to
the breaking point but the space c
analogy i think is
one of the more useful
[Applause]
as the dutch controlled the seas in the
1700s as the british tended to police
and control the seas from the 1800s and
1900s
and as the united states has done in the
20th century and will do in the 21st
century
and that is to ensure that commerce is
unfettered
pirates and others should they be out
there are taken out
we can do the same thing for space we
can do so in a way that is good for
everyone and is good for ourselves
it is policing the heavens for the good
of all may i have the spelling of your
vessel's name captain
object when the united states navy
deploys hundreds of heavily armed
warships in every one of the world's
oceans
no one accuses us of contributing to the
weaponization of the sea
because they know that the presence of
our weapons ensures free transit for all
who pursue their peaceful
interests u.s systems based in space
could similarly
patrol the commons for the good of all
the u.s air force has been charged with
the mission
of ensuring space access and denying
space access in times of conflict
can the united states air force do this
mission
without weapons
what constitutes a space weapon
[Music]
how much do we know about the ability of
the united states to police the heavens
and deny access to others
[Music]
starfire has been used primarily in the
past to do research on satellite
tracking
also they've done a lot of work in
astronomy with
range finding of stars so you use the
laser to be able to
help tell you where the star is and how
far away it is
in the budget documents from the air
force
there has also been mention of the use
of starfire for anti-satellite weapons
activities
the air force told congress that it had
no intentions of using
starfire for anything related to
anti-satellite weapons
however they are doing a test to make
the laser beam very skinny
and make it stay very stable as it goes
up and they're going to target that
on a satellite
[Music]
if you're tracking a satellite you don't
need a very skinny
laser beam in fact you want kind of a
wide one because you
want to be make sure you catch it in the
view right
so many of us here are concerned
that this kind of a test is actually an
anti-satellite weapons test
in disguise
[Music]
in april of 2005
the air force launched an experimental
satellite
its name was the xss 11.
theoretically this experimental
micro satellite has the ability to
disrupt
other nations satellites
has it done so no could it do so
or prancing okay but in reality
we don't know
one of the things that i think people
need to know is that most technology
that's used in space
can be used either for weapons purposes
or it can be used for totally benign
good
purposes lasers for tracking good idea
more precise tracking
um small micro satellites that can go
around a big satellite and take pictures
good idea because it helps you figure
out what went wrong with your satellite
and that's hard to do right now
good idea that same little micro
satellite that's going around the big
satellite
could be set up to go around another
person's cell light and run into it and
kill it
the technology doesn't know whether it's
a weapon or whether it's a
you know a benign use the question is
going to come down to the intent of the
people who are building these systems
how can we discern peaceful or hostile
intentions
for any system projected into space
how can we know that the weaponization
of space hasn't already become
[Music]
i'm the permanent professor and head of
the department of astronautics here at
the air force academy
and we've been continually teaching the
fundamentals of astronautics to our
cadets and every cadet that has
graduated from the air force academy
almost 40 000 now have taken at least
one course in our department
this area right here what's that called
bow shock right
and superimposed on this of course we
have a helo
highly elliptic orbit they start in
military strategy
it shows that if you want to control the
battlefield you need to be the first in
seizing the high ground
the most advanced frontier whether it be
land sea
air and out space the person that
controls that has the advantage so
making sure that we can deny our enemies
space
is a huge advantage
military forces have always relied
upon high ground technologies to gain
advantages
in our own civil war in the united
states
troops in the army especially in the
union army used hot air balloons
to get above the trees and see where the
enemy was and of course
the first airplanes to be used in world
war one were essentially reconnaissance
craft
they were designed to fly up and look
and see where the enemy was placed
space then has been called the ultimate
high ground
and the advantage to the state that can
seize and maintain the high ground is
the same as holding the high ground
throughout history whether that was a
hill a mountain or in
in the latter half of the 20th century
the airspace
september 6 1944 armed with over a ton
of high explosives
germany's first tactical rocket now
called the v2
the vengeance weapon is fired at london
[Music]
hitler's army pioneered the new high
ground with the v2 rocket
vengeance weapon 2 was the first
man-made object projected through space
on route to target in europe
[Music]
set
[Music]
a young ss officer werner von braun
was chief engineer for the design and
manufacturer of the v2
this first ballistic missile sparked the
interest of a rich patron
beyond germany
[Music]
[Music]
the pentagon commissioned von braun and
his team of german rocketeers
to design an improved version of the v2
von braun spearheaded production of the
redstone
the first american ballistic missile
it propelled him to the highest fear of
military and scientific influence
verner von braun ultimately became
associate
director of nasa and his former nazi
scientists functioned as
collaborators with the u.s military
in looking towards space
as a new arena of war
[Music]
uh gentlemen will you please take your
seat so we can begin today's conference
i take great deal of pleasure in
presenting to you today as our guest
speaker dr
werner von braun gentlemen the conquest
of outer space
is the greatest technological challenge
of the age in which we live
on the right side of this picture you
see a large
wheel shaped space station this of
course offers tremendous possibilities
to reconnaissance and both in the
civilian sense
as in the military sense these uh nazi
scientists these nazi space scientists
that
came to this country under project
paperclip developed uh
schemes to essentially control
the earth from space with space-based
weapons
it seems even feasible to use such a
platform
in space as a base for the bombing of
objects on the ground and it is my
opinion
that such bombing could be carried out
with an unprecedented accuracy
from certification
the preparedness
then october 4th 1957
russia shocks the free world the ussr
hurls into orbit the world's first
earth satellites footnick won
the soviets are now the unquestionable
leaders in the race for space
we've been assigned the mission of
launching a scientific earth satellite
i promised the secretary of the army
that we would be ready in 90 days or
less
let's go werner
military's 90-day deadline
his modified v2 launched the first
american satellite into orbit
the space race was on news is flashed of
the long-awaited event
america has earned that light in order
[Music]
how would nations legislate this new
realm
well i joined the american diplomatic
service
in 1958 and i was assigned to the united
nations political office
and i was 22 years old i was the
youngest foreign service officer in the
state department
and they said why don't you handle the
multilateral aspects of our space
program
we just put our first satellites into
space and they said you're in charge
and i said you've got to be kidding i'm
only 22. and they said
that's that's your job
today outer space is free
it is unscarred by conflict
no nation holds a confession there
it must remain this way nothing
was settled when we started for instance
who owns
who owns outer space who owns the moon
who owns mars
uh was it the situation like columbus
discovering the new world
and he says i lay claim to america in
the name of the king
and queen of spain
could we do that could the russians do
that so that was
a big question and the other question is
are we going to use outer space for
peaceful purposes or for military and
aggressive purposes
we must develop new concepts which
enable us
let's say something like 10 years from
now to land parties on the moon
to decide whether we want to have a base
on the moon for scientific
or military purposes and we thought to
ourselves
can there be one part one one sector
that is free of weapons but when it got
to the peaceful uses question
uh we i ran into the department of
defense
and they said no we don't want to give
up
the idea of putting weapons into outer
space
we'll go along with not having weapons
of mass destruction
in outer space but we're not going to
sign on a treaty where we
can't put up weapons
i lost the state department lost the
department of defense won
and we ended up with a treaty the 1967
treaty
which said you can't orbit weapons of
mass destruction
but it did not prohibit other weapons
world leaders compelled by the influence
of the defense department
endorsed the militarization of space
[Music]
nuclear weapons were now banned from
space
but on earth they were proliferating
with both sections of this divided world
in possession of unbelievably
destructive weapons
mankind approaches a state where mutual
annihilation becomes
a possibility earth satellites
in themselves have no direct present
effect upon the nation's security
however there is real military
significance to these launching
dreading nuclear attack the us and ussr
longed to know the position and power of
its enemy stockpiles
each dispatch satellites to spy day and
night
over the other's arsenal the military
contest to occupy the ultimate high
ground
had begun
the united states plotted the next step
to weaponize space
covertly in the early 80s
june 12 1982
there was a huge demonstration in new
york city that day
almost a million people were protesting
against
nuclear weapons at that time the height
of the cold war between the united
states
and the former soviet union but i
watched it
on television and after it was over they
cut away to a right wing conference
and the speaker that day was a man by
the name of lieutenant general daniel
graham
and at that time he was ronald reagan's
head of
sdi strategic defense initiative someone
said general graham aren't you worried
about that demonstration in new york
today
they say there's almost a million people
there protesting against nuclear weapons
he said no i think it's fantastic
they're out there protesting against
intercontinental ballistic missiles and
we're moving into space
they don't have a clue let them keep
doing what they're doing
what if we could intercept and destroy
strategic ballistic missiles before they
reached our own soil or that of our
allies
it will take years probably decades of
effort on many fronts
there will be failures and setbacks just
as there will be successes and
breakthroughs
but isn't it worth every investment
necessary to free the world from the
threat of nuclear war
my fellow americans tonight we're
launching an effort which holds the
promise of changing the course of human
history
i ask for your prayers and your support
thank you good night when i joined the
staff
of the committee on armed services in
the u.s house of representatives
back in 1985 my first assignment
was to investigate and oversee
the strategic defense initiative this
was president ronald reagan's
star wars program this new national
strategy
represents a break from the dangerous
policy of mutual assured destruction
in ronald reagan's version of star wars
the new space shuttle
would deploy the force when our
reconnaissance systems verify a soviet
launch u.s
interceptors are fired as level 1
defense goes into action
batteries of orbiting weapons would be
poised to defeat a nuclear attack
before it reached u.s airspace
at the time the prevailing view was that
this was going to work
that the technology was almost in hand
and that this was going to change
everything i remember the briefing i got
from my staff director who said
not just anti-missile systems but all
major weapon systems were going to move
to space that space was the new
high ground even then we talked about in
that way where
where all major military operations were
going to be by the
the end of that century it was a debate
of stellar proportions
the nation's number one star gazer
versus the pentagon's chief of star wars
it cannot protect the population of the
united states
it can be by the soviets overwhelmed
outfoxed underflown i for one am not
willing
and able to just accept the idea
that it can't work most star wars plans
proved too fanciful
and went no further than animations
devised for publicity
but the us military stayed committed to
star wars
[Music]
as the u.s became the sole superpower
the pentagon maintained its plan to use
space weapons
against enemy attacks star wars
resurfaced in the early 21st century
under a new name missile defense
we need a new framework that allows us
to build missile defenses
to counter the different threats of
today's world we'll also move forward on
ballistic missile defense cooperation we
must develop
and we must deploy effective missile
defenses
back in 2000 when president bush took
office
he and his cadre of people that
surrounded him
you think of paul wolfowitz you think of
donald rumsfeld
yeah you think of dick cheney all of
them really only had two priorities
one was to get rid of saddam hussein the
second
was to build a missile defense system
good morning i've just concluded a
meeting of my national security council
we reviewed what i've discussed with my
friend
president vladimir putin over the course
of many meetings
many months and that is the need for
america
to move beyond the 1972
anti-ballistic missile treaty when
george
w bush became president immediately he
gave
six-month notice to russia that we're
pulling out the united states is pulling
out of the abm treaty the anti-ballistic
missile treaty
that limited the united states ability
to test and deploy
anti-satellite weapons so-called missile
defense systems and other space
technology
at the pentagon today a warning that
space will become the next big
battleground
to meet the challenge defense secretary
donald rumsfeld is making space a
top pentagon priority putting a
four-star general at the head of a new
air force base command
to take charge of all military space
activity
including any new anti-missile defense
pay careful attention to protecting
promoting our interest in space
pentagon officials say it's the first
step toward eventually putting weapons
into space
mr secretary the budget proposes
spending eight point three billion
dollars on
the full range of ballistic missile
defense programs
this is an increase over last year
nearly sixty percent
or three billion dollars it is a lot of
the taxpayers money
on the other hand the president intends
to have ballistic missile defense to
protect the population centers of the
united states as well as of our friends
and allies and deployed forces
[Music]
i have a valid missile event i agree
that's a valid event you have two
today's air force fights missile defense
war games in which so-called rogue
nations attack american cities
possible impact in san francisco sir in
reality
who would launch such attacks against
the usa
the interesting thing is that the threat
is actually shrinking not increasing
the ballistic missile threat is
declining there are far
fewer ballistic missiles in the world
now than there were 15 years ago there
are fewer countries with ballistic
missile programs
there are fewer hostile countries to the
united states with ballistic missile
programs
when you start when you look at it it
really comes down to a handful of states
whose programs
we worry about north korea and iran
basically
and they only have medium-range missiles
that is they can't reach the united
states
from ronald reagan onwards every
president has secured funding for
missile defense
under various guises using various funds
for a total of at least 200 billion
dollars
are u.s taxpayers getting what they pay
for
it's a con it's a con missile defense is
the greatest fraud
in the department of defense and believe
me it's had a lot of competitors
i i really i i really believe this i i
missile defense is the longest running
fraud
in the in the history of the u.s
department of defense
[Music]
if a ballistic strike is implausible why
repel it at such cost
from space what if missile defense
disguised ambitions broader than
destroying only missiles
there's going to be an inherent
anti-satellite capability with any
ballistic missile defense system
regardless of whether it's
located in space or elsewhere and i
think that that's
effectively unavoidable targeting a
ballistic missile in some senses is more
difficult
than targeting a satellite and therefore
targeting a satellite is almost always a
capability
that's associated with missile defense
system
in february 2008 the united states
destroyed a disabled satellite of its
own
with missile defense interceptors
the u.s demonstrated that these
interceptors
also called kill vehicles can obliterate
any satellite
in low earth orbit missile defense is a
trojan horse
it has nothing to do with defense
whatsoever it's all about projecting
power
it's about offense i've been to the
bases in colorado springs and i've
personally seen
over the door where it says master of
space
and i've read the documents vision for
2020 and a whole
array of other military space command
documents that have said for years
that the u.s will control space that we
will dominate space
that we will deny other countries access
to space
we five percent of the world's
population in the united states
are going to deny other countries access
to space
i mean absolutely provocative i would
tell you that
we are so dominant in space that
i pity a country that would come up
against us
the synergy with air land and sea forces
and
our ability to control the battle space
and seize the high ground
is devastating we're going to rail 38
out of 7
is open time is good no open jobs until
1727.
america now has the chance to establish
an american empire pax american
that will last for many many decades
and one of the ways to do this is to
establish
strong american control of space
[Music]
by advancing space weaponry the united
states nurtures its economy
and its fear of control it guards
interests at home
and to the outermost frontiers in the
tradition
of empires if you look at history
countries including the united states
had to at first develop armies
to defend themselves so the united
states needed an
army to defend itself against the
indigenous population who we were
exterminating as we
expanded across the national territory
and to defend ourselves against uh
mexico and we stole half of mexico and
so on and so forth for that he needed
armies and
also intervention and so on and then
countries also developed navies like you
know the british had to develop a navy
to defend themselves against people in
india
and africa and so on uh and
as they describe it they they're pretty
frank about it they say they had to
develop navies to protect
uh commercial interests and investment
uh and same with us uh and now there's a
new frontier
space and we have to
move on to control space in order to
protect commercial interests and
investments
welcome to the future
the place you go when you say here's to
bigger profits
better business brighter prospects and a
bottom line that just won't quit
think big big tax advantages big
business opportunities
big profits and the hottest fortune 500
industries in the world
are taking advantage of them which means
whether you're looking to relocate
expand or conquer the known universe
with your own special vision of the
capitalist's dream they
can help make it happen please welcome
creator air force base general kevin
it's nice to be here in colorado springs
for this this great gathering
and i think it's fitting that we're here
in colorado because
i think it was yeah i know it was 25
years ago when the first commander
of air force space command stood up the
flag here general james hardinger
he said that colorado springs would
become the nation's military space
capital
and indeed it has
[Music]
in colorado springs you will find a
different
kind of base of both direct military and
military contractors
approaching one third of the entire
population and when you think about it
that is a big number
the industrialists are now saying we're
not going to make cars anymore
we're not going to make clothes in
america anymore we're not going to make
this and that in america anymore we're
going to make weapons
this is our space tracking surveillance
system
and this is a more advanced version
of a missile detection satellite
to detect track and discriminate
missiles in flight so this finds them
somebody else shoots them down
we're working on some of the world's
most important and spectacular
technologies
and we're the best in the world at what
we do
while most u.s industries struggle to
endure a recession
the weaponization of space still feeds
thriving corporations with contracts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
here on our right we see one of the new
guys in
town s i international companies that
are growing very quickly
that no one has heard of before such as
l3
communications sparta
these are names that are not familiar
names to people and yet
they are the new strong players in
military contractors
you have the aerospace corporation on
your right
[Applause]
you have mitre corporation on your left
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
as we cross over here you will see a
lockheed martin plant
now here to our right is northrop
grumman
northrop grumman has always been a big
contractor
but a couple of years ago it bought out
trw
corporation and so now it is one of the
biggest military contractors in the
world
this is the kind of new growth we are
seeing in colorado springs
[Applause]
[Music]
out of every tax dollar in the united
states today
50 cents out of every single tax dollar
goes to the pentagon for past wars
for current wars for future wars
[Applause]
we are being made into a warrior culture
if you will
[Music]
nearly three-quarters of a million
remarkable individuals
serving their country and they all
believe
they have the best job in the world
[Music]
how cool is it to be able to go home at
night and tell your kids that you fly
satellites at geosynchronous orbit
that is great stuff how cool is it to
know that you operate the most powerful
radars in the planet and surveil the
heavens that you operate telescopes
that are critical to national defense
[Music]
how cool is it to tell people that you
are responsible for maintaining
nuclear missiles on alert for the
defense of this country
[Music]
this is a cool business that we are in
join us america's air force
no one comes close
[Music]
this is our larger laboratory and off to
this side we have freshmen or first-year
cadets
working on components of our falconsat 5
satellite that we're in the process of
designing
and we'll be testing those at kirtland
air force base in new mexico
since i was a kid i've been fascinated
with aviation
and space exploration so after high
school i started looking at colleges
and the air force looked really cool
because i could learn about space
technology
and satellite design so the air force
academy
was just the natural choice
[Music]
crazy
[Music]
awesome we're at the air force starbase
la luz academy
at kirtland air force base and we've got
students working on
a engineering piece of software to
design a space station so if they were
trying to present their model to
somebody to
buy or to be excited about that's cool
there are all kinds of stories across
the country now
where young people in their schools are
being indoctrinated
at very young ages in this warrior
culture
and in new space technology
each year over 50 000 children are
educated in space technology
at military bases in most states across
the u.s
the pentagon takes a long-term view
seeking to enlist generations of youth
in richly subsidized aerospace careers
it's extremely important for us to have
students learning about science
technology engineering and mathematics
as our workforce continues to age we
need to make sure that we have
young people in the pipeline that are
interested in filling those career slots
that our future our current scientists
and engineers are in
[Music]
i would argue there is no better time
than today
for us all to commit to a future of
excellence
and leadership fueled by the next
generation of our airmen
ladies and gentlemen we're ready today
with our great industry partners
with you at our side we'll be ready for
tomorrow god bless you and thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the pentagon has said that moving the
arms race into space
will be the largest industrial project
in the history
of the planet earth they can't take any
chances
they have to have an enemy they have to
make
the people afraid someone's going to
attack us with nuclear weapons
we've got to have missile defense in
order to protect us from attack
iraq one of the rogue states
iran north korea and now they throw
china into that
equation wait a minute
what about the chinese threat didn't
china like the u.s
show that it can destroy orbiting
satellites
isn't china trying to gain military
superiority in space
the threat to our space security is real
kind of an electronic pearl harbor that
could only be aimed at the united states
there are individuals who are
hyping the chinese threat saying that
it's imminent
that it's aggressive that they plan to
launch a preemptive
massive attack on u.s space systems in
the pacific
which they call a space pearl harbor and
they often look for these
stories these sensational stories in
newspapers or tabloids
and these publications tend not to be
very reliable
for example this parasite satellite
story
where a hong kong tabloid published
a bit of information it got off of a
chinese website
and then this made it into u.s pentagon
reports to congress
and nobody ever bothered to figure out
if this original chinese website
source was credible or not and as it
turns out
uh the the person who was posting this
it was on his personal
web page his sort of own personal blog
and he was really just sort of making it
up
and if you look at all of the other
things on his site which include things
like
pictures of you know scantily clad women
and
sensational photographs of secret weapon
systems he's clearly not
a credible source of information
they didn't bother to trace the
information to its source
which took us about six hours to do
for the last three years the pentagon
has been trying to make china the new
boogeyman
and china unwittingly played into the
united states hands with its
anti-satellite test
[Music]
at the time i was at a conference in
colorado springs
and the military officers in the room
actually left to watch
the test uh in real time
so they were observing the actual
chinese
anti-satellite test we know about
every space launch we know about every
rocket launch we have reconnaissance and
surveillance satellites that can detect
all these
we detected the chinese test for example
and in fact
we detected the two previous chinese
tests that failed
so we know about this it's extremely
difficult to hide
[Music]
space tests they're one of the most
observable weapons tests you can
possibly imagine
what was the point of china's display of
destruction
the reason is simple they want to give
you a signal
a warning so the warning must be known
by the other side in effect the chinese
were saying
okay you want to be dominant in space
you deal with us
china intended to alert the world to u.s
plans for military dominance of space
[Music]
and china warned it will confront that
ambition
it is able and willing to destroy us
weapons in space
we wouldn't really want to see in the
future
an earth surrounded by an outer layer
of weapons which will make
mankind even more vulnerable than the
situation today
china offered a preview of the deadly
contest that would start
if the us positions weapons in space
close is that risk the us military
is developing what the air force in
particular has called
prompt global strike that is basically
currently we have nuclear missiles that
could strike anywhere on earth within 30
minutes
what the military is talking about is a
similar
conventional capability that could be
used to knock out
say a chinese anti-satellite weapons
launcher
in a matter of minutes
a number of concepts are being studied
with this notion
of prompt global strike one is a uh
orbiting space plane that would have the
capability to be able to maneuver
and also to fire weapons at a much
faster pace
than is currently the case
another is a space satellite that would
actually have
missiles on it that could be fired uh
from space
and reach a target in literally uh
five to ten minutes as opposed to the
current 30 minutes
we're talking about a satellite a system
called rods from god which can
put heavy tungsten metal rods
from satellites onto the earth to
penetrate bunkers
all that's being developed we've spent
billions of dollars on research on these
on these weapons
and a number of these weapons are
getting ready for
testing were they deployed in orbit
global strike systems could hit 100
targets on earth at once
at nearly 7 000 miles an hour they
wouldn't be weapons of mass destruction
as defined in u.n resolutions but the
destructive impact of a rod from god
would match that of a nuclear warhead
satellites can identify a target through
overhead imagery
process communications about the target
between military decision makers
and then guide a bomb precisely enough
to destroy the target with one shot
would it really be that big a step if a
projectile itself were also launched
from space
there's no practical difference and i'd
venture to say that the person on the
receiving end wouldn't see the
distinction either
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the high-tech field there's an ocean
called normal accident
it means the kind of accident that is
going to take place
unpredictably in any complicated system
like anyone who owns a computer knows
about normal accidents
every once in a while the thing there's
crashes for some unexplained reason
and when you get to much more complex
systems of course that's going to happen
with all our technology we know bloody
well
that we cannot be assured absolutely 100
percent
that our bombs so-called think bombs
smart bombs
are hitting the targets we know from
afghanistan and
iraq alone in the last few years that
that's a fallacy
you are hitting civilian people you are
not hitting the iraqi
bases what you are doing is wrong how
much worse
would the probability of hitting the
wrong target
or hitting ourselves from outer space
would be
we have no way of calculating that it's
not possible
at least one weapon could go awry and
land in iowa
or new york city or god knows where you
know
uh that's a reality and if if we don't
accept that well we're just whistling in
the dark
and we're going to be victims of our own
technology
[Music]
[Music]
the rest of the world understands that
the us is planning to militarize space
of course
so there have been efforts to renew and
extend
the outer space treaty
it says weapons of mass destruction
can't be in space it doesn't say other
things
and there have been attempts to renew it
just to affirm it and to strengthen it
now the u.s blocks it every year
[Music]
it is 160 to 1
170 to 1. the united states is the only
nation actually voting against this
we're isolated
on this issue
it would be nice to think that
space weaponization is prevented
not because there's a huge outcry
against it although that would be
an interesting prospect too but because
no one including our own nation has the
money to spend on this anymore
but in an era when the united states
still maintains a 500
billion dollar military budget every
year
i don't think we can count on that
happening it's really insane
we are willing to spend hundreds of
billions of dollars over the years to
develop
space control means that a treaty would
take care of
would make unnecessary if we had the
will to
negotiate such a treaty if we took the
lead
we could get one it wouldn't be easy it
would be a very difficult thing to do
but it could be done
how can a treaty ban all anti-satellite
weaponry
a ground-based laser a conventional
missile and most orbiting systems can be
used to demolish satellites
could a treaty guarantee that kill
vehicles would only target missiles
not satellites or earth-bound objects
opponents of a new treaty argue that
such promises are untenable
and too late
[Music]
weaponization of space has happened
a long time ago this idea that it's a
pristine environment
that if only we stop where we are right
now
all will be well is simply nonsense and
it's even more foolish
to think that somehow we can stuff this
genie into a bottle
we do indeed need a united nations
treaty
this is not enough this is only step one
step two says okay
space has been militarized there are
military networks in space
many of them like gps are useful but we
should
work on international treaties to make
those military space networks
used for multilateral purposes do i
think that's going to happen
i'm i'm very doubtful but i have to keep
hoping and believing that there is a
prospect for that
i will cut tens of billions of dollars
in wasteful spending
i will cut investments in unproven
missile defense systems
i will not weaponize space
those fearing the weaponization of space
could find hope in barack obama's
election
as soon as he took office the white
house announced it would be seeking a
worldwide ban on weapons
that interfere with military and
commercial satellites
but it proved tough to change decades of
entrenched military policy
to weaponize space
obama's 2010 defense budget requested
close to a billion dollars that was
applicable
to space warfare systems
it included a new program called
offensive counter space
which the pentagon defined as offensive
measures to disrupt
deny degrade or destroy
any adversary space capabilities
[Music]
history suggests that nations do not
voluntarily disarm
they disarm because they're defeated
or they make small adjustments in the
way
they buy and build and deploy their
weapons
but no superpower says
you know it would be better if we were
weaker
i don't recall that ever happening
two yeah three
four five
six seven
eight
it's hard to obtain space superiority
without attacking
so i'm afraid that if we want space
superiority
we're going to have to attack in these
assets which
i don't know if you know much about
orbital mechanics but if you created
debris up in space
that would just get in the way for you
as well and it kind of started chain
reaction
and pretty soon you just have a cloud of
debris surrounding earth
about 600 000 fragments rushed through
space
at 10 times the velocity of a rifle
bullet
all of these objects are traveling at 14
000 miles an hour
so even an object the size of a pea
traveling at that speed has
more force than a than a cannonball
right now the problem with space junk is
so high that nasa is worried that if
there is never another
launch of anything into space because
every
launch creates a little bit of debris
in 50 years time certain orbits will be
so polluted that nobody can operate
there
because the stuff that's already up
there will start breaking up and
creating more and more clutter
a satellite's destruction unleashes a
storm cloud of debris
that fowls the space around our planet
and threatens anything in orbit
the point really is this creation of
debris in this manner
a good idea or a bad idea and clearly it
is a very bad idea
because there's no way to go up and
clean that up
the more times you go into space
and you begin to practice destroying
other
satellites you create so much space junk
that you literally create the very
likely possibility
that at some point in time you will not
be able to get a rocket off the planet
earth
because it'll be like a minefield around
the planet
and you won't be able to escape the
minefield with that rocket because it
would be destroyed
by all the space junk there so we've got
to begin to look at spaces and
environment
[Music]
we have several hundred billion dollars
of investment in the peaceful uses
of outer space i'm talking about weather
satellites
positioning satellites scientific
satellites
the entire world communication network
is all satellite oriented
all this incredible investment from the
united states and from the european
union and canada and other countries
like this
all this is completely a jeopardy
if we start putting weapons in outer
space
how would our world change if we lost
the use of satellites
day one 6 15 am communication satellites
hovering over the america's fall mute
over a swath of the globe gps coverage
collapses
atomic clocks on gps satellites can't
transmit universal standard time
the synchronization of massive
infrastructures snaps
350 million cell phones are disabled
hundreds of millions of internet
connections vanish
around the world card payments and bank
accounts freeze
billions of dollars are sucked from
industries and businesses triggering a
financial crash
new services are crippled city streets
reliant on gps for traffic management
are in chaos
electrical grids lose synchronization
wide zones of continents are blinded by
blackouts
coast guards are deaf to ships distress
calls
dozens of aircraft are missing air
traffic controllers are fighting panic
worldwide flights are grounded or called
back
by midnight there's been a cascade of
traffic train
boat and aircraft accidents
so far the world has avoided such a
catastrophe
but a space war would kill satellites
and blast tons of wreckage into orbit
the system we rely on would shatter
and be impossible to restore
the time is 6 25 and this is a special
as part of the conference on world
affairs
we're discussing the militarization of
space there is a point in time that may
be rapidly closing where the united
states could dominate space to such a
point where there would be no arms race
frankly i don't think it's doable i i
think the march of technology will mean
that even if we get a lead
on other nations in attempting to do
that that sooner or later we will again
be challenged
it's kind of like what happened after
world war ii we had the atomic bomb
nobody else had the atomic bomb
we thought we had a big exclusive and
without atomic weaponry
we would be able to dominate the earth
it didn't last very long the soviets had
an atomic bomb the chinese had an atomic
likewise in space to think that we can
move up there with weaponry
and be alone to be the the king
on the uh throne of space
it's a tragic miscalculation
especially
india has been discussing whether or not
it needs to build its own
anti-satellite weapons you can be sure
if india does it pakistan will be
thinking about it in a heartbeat
as well israel has also been discussing
this issue so
what you see now is the potential for a
domino effect
few nations will willingly submit to u.s
supremacy in space
some will try to topple the u.s others
scramble for a foothold
enemies will buy in leaping ahead stable
and unstable nations will be dragged
into the race
the european union opposes the
weaponization of space
but for how long
american continues
to
russia would plunge into the contest it
has committed to destroying any weapon
the u.s positions in orbit
if americans deploy space-based
anti-ballistic missile defenses
then could you imagine interceptors
based
on space stations military stations
would overfly territory of russia
or territory of china
that would be considered as quite
unacceptable i think for russians
[Music]
the potential victims are not going to
say
here's my throat please cut it they know
that they're
a potential target and if the us were to
develop space weapons they'd be
completely defenseless unless they
destroyed it somehow or developed a
deterrent
and deterrence are known so for example
nuclear weapons are deterrent
uh terror is a turn that's why
aggressive militarism leads to an
extension of proliferation and terror
[Music]
[Music]
here
[Music]
during the cold war humankind feared
that in a series of blinding flashes
the world would become an untended
graveyard
[Music]
thousands of nuclear weapons are still
maintained around the world
on hair trigger alert
the weaponization of space could
detonate this arsenal
so any anxiety induced by putting
weapons in space
or launching weapons from space down to
earth
um could induce by accident by human
fallibility by design by terrorists
takeover
the launching of up to
9 000 hydrogen bombs inducing a short
ice age in the death of most creatures
on the planet
we're on the edge of the nuclear
precipice about to be annihilated
if we move to weaponization of space we
can bid farewell to the planet
the chances of survival are very slight
when you all your life have been told
that america
is a exceptional nation that we are
different from the rest
when you're told that all your life you
begin to believe it
i was in the air force i was a young
republican for nixon
[Applause]
and i grew up on the military bases
behind the barbed wire fences
and so everything i really was taught
and was trained in was militarism
and a conservative way of being
conservative way of seeing the world
[Applause]
but now i personally have learned
that what america is doing is not about
defense
it's about offense it's about an
aggressive
military doctrine that talks about
control and domination
i really went through an entire
transformation everything that i knew
i was different but one thing wasn't
different one thing always remained
i realized i had a good heart even as a
conservative as a young
follower of the military i had a good
heart i i
had a good intention and i realized that
many people in the military are that way
that they have a good heart they mean
well they're they're doing what they
think is the right thing to do they want
to protect the country
there are moments that will truly test
the leader within you
test whether you will take the hard path
or the easy path
the wrong path or the right path most
people
want to have a good heart and that when
you challenge them to think
it doesn't mean that they change
overnight i didn't change overnight
it took me some time behind those gates
on that military base for me to make my
change
but it's all about initiating that
change the willingness always to take
the right path
even if it's the hard path is called
character
in every aspect of your life whether
personal or professional
you must always maintain the courage of
your convictions
your personal integrity
[Music]
we're living in a very very dangerous
time and there's hardly
any alarm in this area across the board
i mean people are just
they're so inundated with so many things
you know just making a living just
getting through the day
uh just trying to remain sane in all
this insanity that's going on
that it's hard to get their attention
and saying uh wait a minute i know you
think it's bad
i get news for you it's a lot worse
people don't want to hear that you know
so we have to find a way to alert people
to the reality of what's going on
and that's not an easy task
let's prevent something terrible from
happening before it does for once
usually we're trying to bring back
weapon systems after they've been
deployed nuclear missiles we're trying
to bring them back here's an opportunity
one of the first times in history
actually
that we have a chance to be proactive we
have a chance to
stop a new arms race before it actually
happens that's why
this moment is so crucial
the debate over space weaponization is
the most
critical debate for the next century and
we are on the verge
of making decisions in many nations
around the world
about which path to choose
[Applause]
congratulations may god watch over all
of you
and these united states
lord we pray today that you would allow
us to worship you
in spirit and in truth as we go out into
the world
can the high ground that nation seek be
the moral high ground
or are we doomed to pursue only the high
ground of military advantage
many nations are showing themselves
unwilling to find global peace
under the command of one
[Music]
can the u.s show leadership rather than
strive for supremacy
rather than insisting on a pax americana
can the u.s steer a union of nations
towards a pax
universalis a peace for all the world
in christ's name we pray amen
[Music]
what kind of a peace do we see
not a pax americana enforced on the
world
by american weapons of war
i am talking about genuine peace
the kind of peace that makes life on
earth worth living
not merely peace for americans but peace
for all men and women
not merely peace in our time peace in
all times
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you